[Music]
although it is true that we fall in love
that does not mean that once we fall we
just simply lie there the infatuating
sense of love that we feel when we first
fall for someone cannot last forever
this sensation is merely the brains way
of attempting to motivate reproduction
it comes works to do its job and then
leaves
but the relationship formed from it does
not have to if the relationship is
honest and worthy the true love
underneath can live on true love can
perpetuate when one understands that
like everything in life love goes
through various stages and conditions it
molds to our unique and changing life
and we must adapt and react accordingly
the unconscious and lustful love that we
experience during the honeymoon phase of
relationships is often easy and carefree
but this phase will eventually fade and
you must ensure that the individuals
that you choose to engage in
relationships with for the purpose of
love are individuals of whom you will
still want and enjoy love with when the
roses die
true love requires effort and you must
work to ensure that such effort is
worthwhile like everything in life you
get what you put in and things that are
worth a lot require a lot by being aware
of and embracing the effort that must
come after the initial surge of love
flees you can work to facilitate love
beyond just lust and romance you can
merge your life with another person and
experience the wonder of genuine
connection we must constantly check our
pride and ego within a relationship and
prevent any sense of selfishness within
it you must be mindful and consider what
differences you and your partner have
what is it that they like and that you
do not and vice-versa we must not let
our selfishness prevent us from
providing a balanced and mutual exchange
of love according to each partners needs
and preferences we must constantly make
sacrifices and be willing to give up
portions of our life that help balance
out our partners trusting that they will
do the same for us as scary as this may
be it is one of the only risks worth
taking in life a life experience without
connection and love is a life
unfulfilled it is an incomplete work of
art if we wish to earn the experience of
true love and fulfill the work of art
that is our life we must realize the
balance between the unconscious
infatuating acquisition of love and the
conscious conservation of it
you
you